(whooshing)
- [Narrator] Draw the line.
People make mistakes all the time.
They start companies they
think they can manage.
They have grand and bold visions
that were a little too grandiose.
This is all perfectly fine.
It's what being an
entrepreneur or a creative
or even a business executive is all about.
We take risks.
We mess up.
The problem is that when
we get our identity tied up
in our work, we worry
that any kind of failure
will then say something
bad about us as a person.
It's a fear of taking responsibility,
of admitting that we might have messed up.
It's the Sunk Cost Fallacy,
and so we throw good money
and good life after bad
and end up making
everything so much worse.
Ego kills what we love.
Sometimes it comes
close to killing us too.
"Act with fortitude and honor,"
wrote Alexander Hamilton,
to a distraught friend
in serious financial
and legal trouble of his own making.
If you cannot reasonably hope
for a favorable extrication,
do not plunge deeper.
Have the courage to make a full stop.
History are full of people who
suffered abject humiliations,
yet recovered to have long
and impressive careers.
Politicians who lost
elections or lost offices
due to indiscretions,
but came back to lead
after time had passed.
Actors whose movies bombed,
authors who got writers' block,
celebrities who made gaffes,
parents who made mistakes,
entrepreneurs with faltering companies,
executives who got fired,
athletes who were cut,
people who lived too well
at the top of the market.
All of these folks felt
a hard edge of failure
just like we have.
When we lose, we have a choice.
Are you going to make
this a lose-lose situation
for ourselves and everyone involved?
Or will there be a lose, and then a win?
Because you will lose in life.
It's a fact.
A doctor has to call a time
of death at some point.
They just do.
At any given time in the circle of life,
we may be aspiring,
succeeding, or failing.
With wisdom, we understand
that these positions
are transitory, not
statements about your value
as a human being.
When success begins to
slip from your fingers
for whatever reason, the
response isn't to grip
and claw so hard that you break things.
It's to understand that
you must work yourself back
to the aspirational phase.
You must get back to first
principles and best practices.
"He who fears death will
never do anything worthy
"of a living man," Seneca once said.
You must be strong enough
to maintain your dignity
and self-respect, because
the only real failure
is in abandoning your principles.
Killing what you love
because you can't bear
to part from it is selfish and stupid.
If your reputation can't
absorb a few blows,
it wasn't worth anything
in the first place.
Failure sucks.
Deal with it with
dignity and self-respect.
"It can ruin your life only
if it ruins your character."
Marcus Aurelius.
Draw the line.
(calm music)